au sud de la ville d'odessa mélina huet
bonjour à vous vous êtes l'envoyé
spécial de france 24 dans cette partie
de l'ukraine libye mais on va s'arrêter
un instant pour rappeler codesa avant la
guerre saisis une station balnéaire très
prisée mais aujourd'hui la réalité est
tout autre ce sont les mines les
barrages militaires ou encore le
couvre-feu
tout à fait n'a bien vous pouvez
peut-être apercevoir derrière moi il ya
encore des passants qui profitent des
derniers rayons du soleil c'est un calme
apparent les dernières frappes date de
la fin juillet au lendemain de l'accord
portant sur l'exportation des céréales
ukrainienne depuis les sirènes se font
beaucoup plus rares mais c'est un calme
justement peut-être trop important pour
ces habitants qui découvre une ville
vidée de ses touristes vous l'avais dit
il ya un couvre-feu qui a été imposé à
23 heures en réalité les restaurants en
ferme beaucoup plus tôt normalement il y
a une vie nocturne assez importante
beaucoup de clubs beaucoup de boîtes de
nuit on vient de voir un instant passé d
un enterrement de vie de jeune fille et
bien il faudra aller se coucher d'ici à
deux ou trois heures il se trouve que
vous l'avez dit par le passé c'était une
ville balnéaire avec de nombreux de
nombreux touristes or maintenant il ya
aussi un problème c'est que les plages
et bien sont toutes fermées impossible
d'y accéder pour une simple raison c'est
que l'ukraine a déposé des mines dans la
mer pour empêcher une éventuelle
offensive russe par la mer et donc
depuis interdiction de se baigner même
si certains à brave les interdits ça a
coûté la vie d'ailleurs à un baigneur
ukrainien à la fin juin nous disaient
les autorités ukrainiennes il se trouve
également que pour les touristes donc
c'est une très belle ville en eau
dessalée de nombreux bâtiments
architecturaux qui sont enviées dans
toute l'ukraine et bien possibilité de
faire des photos comme on l'entend
puisqu'il ya des barrages militaires un
petit peu partout donc il n'est pas rare
que les militaires viennent vérifier les
téléphones des passants supprime de même
toutes les photos qui ont été prises
donc tout cela change évidemment la vie
de ce port de cette station balnéaire et
nous avons pu nous entretenir avec le
manager d'un hôtel le responsable d'un
hôtel 4 étoiles resort qui accueille
normalement jusqu'à 400 personnes par
jour est bien en ce moment cet hôtel est
quasiment vide le mac même qu'ils ont pu
atteindre ces 25 % de capacité
normalement des touristes viennent d'un
peu partout de l'europe mais également
de turquie ou encore d'israël ou
d'arabie saoudite est bien là il n'y a
que des ukrainiens et justement
aujourd'hui nous avons pu parler à des
touristes ukrainien qui venait passer à
quelques jours à odessa y venait de me
coller c'est à peine à deux heures de
route d'ici et il disait vouloir
s'échapper de cette ville qui est
pilonnée depuis plusieurs semaines une
jeune mère nous disait on fait ça pour
les enfants parce que vous imaginez
devoir des murs qui tremblent d'avoir du
plâtre qui tombent du plafond
régulièrement c'est un enfer alors
qu'ici on a du mal à s'imaginer cette
réalité parallèle on peut regarder des
spectacles avec des dauphins c'est
quasiment irréel pour elle merci d'avoir
partagé ces témoignages merci à vous
mélina merci également au parsons et l'a
aidé à vous avec qui vous accompagnent